[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
honest trailers commentaries for
crew ella where we watch the trailer
together we talk about our behind the
scenes thought process we'll show you
some cut jokes we'll answer some
comments and questions from people like
yourselves and we'll tease you with next
week's honest trailer
y'all know the drill hey danielle hey
lon hi
hello hey happy tuesday uh we're gonna
talk about a film that
i don't know it's only like three weeks
old but i feel like it was a lifetime
ago
cruella yeah um a film that i think has
been
uh i don't to say unfairly maligned but
i i i a movie i would have enjoyed had
it been 30 minutes shorter which i find
myself saying a lot these days maybe i'm
just getting old
um but this is a film that i had fun
with
uh i like emma stone's performance i
like the setting of it i like
i like a punk-ish pre-punk 1970s london
setting i think they pulled that off
well
um i liked um 99 out of 134 of the music
cues that they dropped in
yeah which is a good ratio a lot of
needle drops yeah
and um i think that they had uh that
that it was a
uh a coward's way out to avoid the way
they
uh avoided the puppy killing or
subverted or or whatever but we'll we'll
get into that later but i liked most of
this movie um
what what say yee uh danielle lon what
do you think about this
this one uh yeah i feel like i gotta say
i co-sign with you i really like the
setting
um i liked the the needle drops and i do
think that they kind of
had as far as the coward's way out like
they had an impossible task you have to
take the puppy killi lady
and make her someone that you want to
root for through the power of fashion
um and that's a really hard thing to do
and i think that
for me at least they pulled it up i
thought that it was a fun movie and
you know for talking about sequels i'd
be very interested to see if they decide
to do a sequel like where that's going
to wind up going
well i have a response what's your take
i think my
my issues here are almost all conceptual
like the execution i was almost
entirely fine with i thought emma
thompson was great i thought paul
walker houser was super good and really
funny
i had a lot of fun watching the movie i
agree it's way too long
i agree the needle drops are like i
would have really liked it if they
zeroed in on the arrow like really give
you that
70s london early punk
vibe and they they're all over the place
like
they'll pick any song from the 60s or
70s it doesn't even have to be from
england they're like ah good enough and
it just becomes a hodgepodge
so but overall i thought it was like a
fun movie that i enjoyed watching i just
like
i wish a movie like this didn't have to
be tied into the 101 dalmatian
verse like i wish you could just make a
movie about
a rivalry in london fashion in the 70s
and do all the fun stuff they wanted to
do and they just didn't need it to be
about the crazy old lady from that
cartoon
because that stuff is just it's weird
and i don't understand why all of our
stories have to
do that and can't just stand on their
eyes
i do understand it from a practical
perspective i've just i
it's just a lament like i wish that we
just gave
filmmakers like this the freedom to make
stories in worlds of their own creation
instead of having to worry about like
oh crap who what fashion character do we
tie this into you know it's just like i
mean
that's the stuff that works the least
well and is the least interesting to me
and if it was to be tied into any
franchise or any recognizable thing this
makes way more sense as a
devil wears prada sort of highlander-ish
prequel where like this
fashion rivalry has been going on for
ages and they just yes
until one of them uh cuts the other
one's head off with some fabric shares
uh they have but like even that what
you're now pitching like a world of like
endless
fashion rivalries for supremacy
like i already like that more than
putting it in the world of 101
dalmatians
yeah i mean i say the uh circling back
to what uh danielle said if like
you like how they kind of had their cake
and needed to i mean i
it didn't ruin the movie for me but i do
think that like
and also like lon said like it's a
conceptual failure because if there's
one thing you know about cruella de vil
it's that she wants to make
clothing out of dog's dead dog skin
that's the one thing you know about her
if you know one thing
and the way they handle that is like
here's a movie about her and it's gonna
be like okay we're gonna make we're
doing it we're gonna make you sympathize
with her we're gonna get you to
understand her perspective and like
but actually she doesn't want to kill
dogs in fact she loves dogs
idiot it's like well that's that's you
just you just dodged them
that's not even the story now have you
gone back i i
why no i'm just like that's why i'm
interested in seeing what a sequel would
be because we know we're never going to
get to the dog murder like how do we do
when do we get to the dog murder effect
no this if 101 dalmatians like if the
sequel to cruella leads into that it's
obviously they're gonna have to go a
totally different we're in an old
universe yeah we're totally up because
they already had the
i feel like there must have been a draft
where she does hate dalmatians because
they killed her mother
her adoptive mother that's the setup for
somebody who wants revenge on that
particular dog breed right like which is
insane and probably the dumbest thing
about it but even that doesn't i
went back last week and watched 101
dalmatians on disney plus which i had
not seen in many years and like
it's very explicit in the movie she
likes the way dalmatians look and she's
just a sociopath
so that it it clearly is not she has a
grudge against dalmatians
it's purely a fashion decision
from cruella's part she's really not a
character she's in like three scenes
and she's just a maniac like she's
purely maniacal and
lives only to kill also it's made pretty
clear that horus and jasper are not her
lifelong friends they are two dudes she
has hired
for this assignment and does not really
know or care
is there such a thing as real dalmatian
coats or is that like a
an invention of wait you mean made out
of actual dogs or just
patterned that way no for real like i'm
talking like in the last hundred years
when there weren't so many uh scruples
about uh
animal products now i think it's just
from this it's a book under one
dalmatians was a children's
book that disney adapted yeah but it's
all based on you know brother's grim
and i think it's basically a real story
this isn't a true story
there's also a whole chunk in the middle
part where it's just like
dogs communicating with one another
across the entire english countryside so
i don't think it's based on a true story
it says you unless they figured out like
that lord of the rings like
light the light the fire and alert the
you know gondor
as a member of the druid community this
is a this is based on our our lord
anyways let's watch the honest trailer
for cruella and we'll stop and start
[Music]
since 1999 we've had quasi-redemptive
villain origin stories for darth vader
the joker maleficent the wizard of oz
hannibal lecter nurse ratched norman
bates
magneto saul goodman godzilla the eggs
from planet of the eggs
venom and the minions but now before we
get the quasi-redemptive villain origin
stories for gru
the wicked witch of the west the
targaryens the bad guy from robocop
the orphan from the orphan movie and
medea
make room in your wallet for one more
village uh pause what's here what's your
guys favorite or most anticipated out of
the list
i want to see the medea movie i'm not
gonna lie medea origins
we we left it out but wonka origins with
timothy chalamet
because it's like he's not a villain
he's like yeah i
i we had pitched it but then we were
like he's not quite
he's not quite villainous enough but i
am excited to see what they do with
industrial revolution set young willy
wonka adventures
it sounds like the dumbest and least
necessary but kind of a
fun premise is to watch dick jones rise
through the ranks of uh
of ocp yeah yeah in like a fake
80s detroit um i mean i i want like
that's the thing is like
i feel like a total hypocrite because i
watch all this stuff like they they know
that they have me it's not like i'm
immune to it
i know they have us because it's uh
because they called it cruella frankly
yeah they called it um
uh estella we we probably i don't know
yeah
but that's what i think we would have
watched i would want to watch it i i get
that it's like a marketing thing for the
math but like
i think those original stories could
still be interesting yeah i would have
watched it if it was called zero
dalmatians if it was called
zero damnation then i definitely would
have been into it
no dalmatians were harmed in the making
of this film i'd watched be like well
weird why would they say that why would
you open with it
[Laughter]
um all right keep going cause here comes
cruella you know the dog murderer from
that old cartoon
but the hair you know the lady with the
hair oh man they're really out of ideas
aren't they
meet estella that's right her name is
slightly different than what you
expected
deal with it she's a fashion designer
with an extra dash of tude
don't look at that dress look at this
dress
and why is she that way because
dalmatians killed her mom
sounds stupid it's actually her real mom
that ordered the dogs to kill
now who's stupid we're missing a
a training montage with um the baroness
and the dalmatians where they're like
practicing that over and over again
because it's a perfect it's a
jump kick that dalmatian is like trained
only to push people off cliffs
he's also getting she gets lucky like
that the woman has to be
waiting on her own right on that balcony
right now i'm saying
it doesn't even work she has to hit her
mark yeah that's where she takes
everyone out for the
uh big reveal heart to hearts that she
has semi regularly
any rival fashion designers just point
right yeah can you just there's an
x right here if you don't mind and then
also not lose any of the dalmatians
either
i know like if somebody like i would
probably try to catch a dog that
jumped on me or or in some way become
entangled but
obviously she doesn't i'm sure she's
burned through 101 dalmatians just
learning that
like uh milo notice over there um
all right keep going isn't just a
misunderstood villain
she's actually the reason 101 dalmatians
exist in the first place
yep the dog parents were brother and
sister and cruella helped him hook up
wait where are you going come on
dalmatian incest isn't weird
how do you think we got dalmatians in
the first place and don't you want to
know the story of her last name
spoilers it's a car hello yeah pause
that was like like you said long that
was some of the least necessary and
least
enjoyable parts of the film i don't need
to know
it's just it's just like it's like the
filmmakers like sitting next to you like
elbowing you in the ribs like i get
it i get it it's not a real last name
of like solo and all these films where
they think that what you're there to do
is to learn
where like the ephemera and the like
little
accoutrements of their life came from
it's like he just han solo just bought a
vest one time he thought it looked good
girl deville it's a it's clearly like a
pseudonym that she thought
sounded cool it's like just a cool
fashion name that she picked
that anyways dumb if you ever feel the
need to add why they got their name you
can just go ahead and cut it
yeah well it's star wars it's
particularly
like at least this is in london where
cruella de vil stands out as a weird
name
han solo is a normal name in the star
wars universe everybody's got a crazy
name like
bump grumps or whatever
who cares trying to explain anybody's
name
in a world where everybody's name is i
know like dexter jetster
lump pumpkin like uh yeah you can be han
solo without
without uh that doesn't nobody's name
mean anything it's star wars she's a
guy's name chewbacca
[Laughter]
it's weird that there's a guy named owen
that's right
whether there's a person in the star
wars universe with a regular name it
stands out it's like oh
luke yeah right like oh yeah
morgan see that up a bit all right keep
going
get ready for a kids movie that appeals
to everyone from adults who love emma
stone
to adults who love emma thompson in the
world's first reimagined period
satirical coming-of-age revenge heist
comedy drama
thriller that's also a prequel journey
to 1970s london
where no one is chainsmoking cigarettes
like it's well like it's 1970s london
for a film and that's the second thing i
know about crowell deville is she had
that long
cigarette holder but it's like you can
threaten to kill a dog
they can't smoke while you do it yeah
just like batman can't um
[Laughter]
glasses ew dumagatu in his derelict face
to catwoman on laundry day because this
film isn't so much about telling a story
as it is an elaborate excuse for two
fashionistas to dress fight each other
finisher
jasper more than just two hired henchmen
they're her lifelong hench family
follow this tight-knit crew of thieves
even though their dogs do all of the
work for them
[Music]
yeah pause i guess if we're talking
execution this is one more thing i point
out there there are a few like repeated
beats like like how the the needle drops
kind of grow tiresome after a while like
the
oh their dogs are so well trained that
they pull off the whole heist is like
we hit that beat like four times and
like twice would have been
there's a lot of like you could cut out
several of the heists
in general or um i think you noted each
one there are four car chases in this
movie yes
yes there are like and we say that it's
for adults who love emma stone
adults who love emma thompson like what
kid is gonna sit for
two hours worth of fashion heisting i i
will say
i saw this uh a friend like rented out
like a little theater and a bunch of us
watch and
two people did bring children and the
kids we watched it with were like
they loved it so maybe we're the city i
chalk that up to the pandemic that they
were just excited they were just happy
to be anywhere
maybe that's true but i know because
that's what i thought like after like
two hours i started getting restless and
those kids were like
yeah tell me more about crew maybe it is
worse when you're at home because like
you don't pause a movie in the theater
but
i swear to god like the last five movies
i've watched at home
i will pause to do something and it's
like oh there's still an
hour left what's happening what happened
to the 90-minute feature
come on army of the dead i swore they
were adding time i
swear every time i pause i feel like i
was further back in the movie
it's crazy yeah yeah home theater
experience it's uh it's different
um yeah all right keep going
[Music]
yeah this is cute and all but hired guy
richie if all you really wanted to see
was a dog snatch
uh moving on and then there's artie
disney's third or fourth first
live-action gay character
who after making a big pr push about
representation
takes things right up to the comfort
zone of your average chinese or russian
sensor
look around cinderella i have everything
a girl or boy could ever want
disney does know liking fashion isn't
the same thing as being queer right
right yeah pause i mean they don't need
to i don't need to see
him have sex with somebody in a
children's movie
i'm just saying they keep tooting their
own horn about this and then not only do
they not put it in the film it's always
like jk rowling like background info
but then they cut those parts when
they're released internationally like
they will
bend over backwards to if there's
anything objectionable
uh uh to play overseas so
yeah and if you include animated
characters like this is like the
what seventh or eighth time disney's
been like i feel like it's getting
gay just about every new movie they come
up with somebody to be like what about
this one that do anything for you yeah
oh yeah like the two chicks who kiss in
the background
of star wars great right or leaner i
feel represented
being away from onward even though
there's not like you know it's so weird
because
you can obviously think of straight
disney characters who don't like have
sex or even like date in the movies they
just
we know that they like the other
attracted to the opposite sex
it's the same it's just like that's all
you have to do you don't have to
they don't have to be like making out in
the movie yeah
right um i think your boyfriend the the
smallest cuttable
and least explicit uh parts possible
this isn't explicit at all he's
literally just a man who likes fashion
and they were like yeah
our work here is done it's like that's
not what no that doesn't make any sense
uh yeah all right keep going looming
over them all
is the baroness who's basically cruella
from the original movie but instead of
killing dogs
she kills people because disney is well
aware
white women care more about dogs than
other human lives
so put the kids to bed and settle in i
did think that
the baroness she's she's cruella
in this movie like she gets all the
this movie if she uh ended that film
like
uh sharpening her her dog knife it would
make more sense
to to have her change her name to
cruella and roll credits or something
like that
which there you go like there you didn't
really you thought one was the carillon
but no it's the other uh that's also
like yeah that would have made more
sense
good twist yeah then there's your twist
there now everyone's happy
[Laughter]
ass kids movie whose two-hour run time
isn't because it's too complex
but because it takes a fun high-fashion
heist concept and awkwardly marries it
to the setup for a 50-year-old dog
cartoon
even though everyone nostalgic for 101
dalmatians will be dead in 10 years come
on
let's make a new movie please we promise
we'll see it
maybe starring
the gown princess of crime peaky blind
positive i think that the uh the
anita and roger was also one of the more
forced uh inclusions in there
like what they do this weird thing where
like everyone's age is now flattened and
everyone grew up with everyone and
it's just so weird and so unnecessary
like they didn't need to be
in the movie literally at all it also
does again
violate 101 dalmatians the whole first
10 minutes of 101 dalmatians is
roger's a lonely bachelor and pongo his
dog is like i'm going to find him a
woman
and it is kind of weird uh but that's
not the story
but in this version in this world roger
and anita already know each other
so that whole opening wouldn't even work
where they meet and fall out now it's
just a dog that wants to find his sister
to hook up
with him well i i will i will there are
three the baroness owns
three dalmatians and we don't know if
those dalmatians are all brother and
sister those could be but they came from
the same litter yeah
the puppies came from puppies from the
same letter for sure
okay i get what you're saying so those
but it was like
couldn't but are we sure they're the
same litter and not
two of emma thompson's dalmatians had
puppies
well two separate like what if like
let's say
emma thompson owns three unrelated
dalmatians a male
and two females so the male and the
female hook up
one of the females hooks up with another
dalmatian we don't see history
dalmatian from i don't know dogs get
around in this world there's a whole
network of
there's a whisper network of them that
stretches across the uk
so okay so if there's two dalmatian
couples and they
each had a litter theoretically pongo
and perdita could have
sounds like the most f'ed up word
problem on the s.a.t.s
let's say two dalmatian couples are
having sex
we're gonna make a fool by the numbers
on this and have it out on the channel
in a couple
i'm just saying you're ready
theoretically they've left a little
window open if they do want to make a
case
that this is a for some enforced mystery
stud
biologically sound kind if that helps
you sleep at night sure
canonically they're related all right
keep going peggy blunders
saving mrs spanx iggy stop
kirby's epic yarn and mark strongest as
a side character
how estella got her crew back
you know it's a good thing emma stone
picked a random car on london street
with the wheel on the proper american
side
yeah um all right i hope somebody got
fired for that blood
for that peaky blonder we didn't mention
it it comes up in the
in the starring how weird is it that
mark's strong there must have been more
to mark strong's ballet character right
yeah it feels like they were like get us
a mark strong type and then he was just
like i'm available
he's like you're too good for this mark
strong get out of here
yeah it did seem like there was some
some cut scenes there he just doesn't
have it doesn't seem like he has enough
to he feels like one scene's missing
where we really get it he gets to go
full mark was he sleeping with the
baroness at some point
maybe is he corella's dad it's weird
that he's there and he seems to have no
problem with her but then the moment
that this opportunity
opens up he's just like betraying her
after decades of service and it's like
wow save it for two ella uh
we have some cut stuff let's see what
our deleted scenes might have been
and travel back to an alternate version
of 1970s london
where the world of high fashion is
diverse using animal products is a
ridiculous idea
but instead of killing dogs she kills
human people
so wait who's the villain in this again
cause she can make a dress out of human
skin and i still root for her over a dog
killer
hands up my pongo
starring cruella did not that bad
actually
black and white privilege dress to
suppress
cruella intentions the deville wears
poca
the devil's detail richard jewel thieves
crooks brothers my best friend shedding
welcome to emma stone's friend zone
dressed to kill
miranda beastly a day to kill for
don't tell mom the baby's not dead
friends with puppy
friendly darling he used to be a vampire
but
now he's a lawyer the dog father
and alfred savage and strong not that
bad actually
and mark strong bad and uncanny valet
all about a bill the truth about brats
and dogs
101 brand integrations
orphan thick
why is roger writing a song about
cruella she just gave you a puppy
shouldn't it be about the lady who was
your boss and also murdered people
yeah yeah they had to describe where the
song came from
i guess i gotta gotta give us that
little little tidbit
i will say uh my one note to uh
epic voice man john bailey who does
amazing work all the time
what should have been he used to be
a vampire but now he's
a lawyer to make the to make the snl
connection
uh that's that's on me i uh i didn't
give him that it's unfortunate
it's the unfrozen caveman lawyer theme
folks got it got it got it
um all right so we've got some live chat
uh questions to get to uh before we do
that thank you so much for watching
please like please subscribe please hit
the bell so you'll never miss another
cruella honest trailer commentary
um are we doing another one we're doing
them every week baby
nice i got lots to say yeah uh adam
halbert writes would you see a cruella
versus john wick movie since mr wick
fights for animal rights
i don't know if that's necessarily true
that he
he's a friend to animals he is also a
druid um but i do think that
i think a real animal rights champion
would not train them to kill
he would use them as weapons of of war
he would he'd like leave the animals out
of it
because he's using those horses to kill
he's using dogs to kill
like come on he's not like exactly a
peta spokesman i feel like if you are
his adversary and you've trained a dog
to attack him he will shoot
your dog it's just his dog yeah
you hate to see it but that's probably
true i'd still see a fashion fight
though
i would say he's very fashionable he
does
just a series of uh mock turtlenecks who
i feel like would be a good adversary
for cruella for the
from the wick verse would be angelica
houston like i'd like to see
her ballet school of assassins against
cruella
and her fashionable high school or um uh
the
morpheus's uh the bowery the bowery
they're definitely hiding in a in a
garbage
dress for sure there were like three of
them
underneath her garbage dress right there
yeah
uh all right evan jay pretzel asked what
villain in all of film or tv deserves a
disney style show from their perspective
i would not mind a show about vader in
his downtime
yeah i guess yeah like a vader sitcom
like
you know he keeps people keep getting
him out of the egg and he's annoyed what
do you want uh i've always felt like dr
doom from marvel has a really cool
interesting like
complex origin story we've never gotten
to explore because the movie's always
totally he's always like a hacker now or
something but like the real like the let
varian dr doom original origin would be
cool
yeah eventually we'll get it on disney
plus yeah i think shang
might be fun um
suck your soul someone someone sucked
his dad's soul and now
no i want the whole thing narrated by
cabal he's gonna get his soul sucked
uh yeah i want the um
uh is it the balrog what is that from
fantasia from like night on uh which
mountain
or no that's um oh what's that guy's
name
it's the ballrog is lord of the rings
what's the uh but
i want him uh to be actually an aspiring
uh fashion person in 1970s london
until a series of mishaps and goofs uh
send them into uh
to become a volcano monster um all right
he's like a boy
living on the mountain who discovers a
magic stone or something no
fashion oh fashion 1970s fashion
ajb 950 writes do you ever get nervous
embarrassed when you release new honest
trailers i thought this was a sweet
question
god i i i um no i if i'm
if i'm embarrassed that's that means
that's a bad sign um
somebody some i feel better about than
others but then they turn out to have no
bearing
on how they're received i'll be like oh
this one's a stinker and it's like this
is the best one
or like this one's hilarious they're
like not your best work
so uh i don't trust my own instincts
except i'm just trying to make we're all
just trying to make each other laugh
right
or do you guys get nervous no i'm
playing
it's like you said i'm just trying to
make you all laugh if i can get a little
like
then i feel good about the joke that i
wrote yeah embarrass
no because i don't really feel like the
they never reflect on me personally like
if they're come out and they're really
terrible i could be like well that was
all that was all danielle
[Laughter]
but no i definitely i wouldn't say
nervous like i'm a ball of anxiety but
there are some where i feel i feel
really good about it and i hope that
people like
like the money plane one we did recently
i was like wow i really hope that
people like it because i liked it so
much and put so much of myself into it
that yeah
it would be disappointing if people
didn't like it but um i think that's
about it
i would say there's nervousness but it's
like because of things of like did we
get the egg roll ad
right it's like or like did we use the
right music like there are we gonna get
flagged because we
yeah 0.6 microseconds of a of a
copywritten song
right yeah yeah that stuff will make
us and our various nerfs and email
threads that's about it
all right i'm going to do an
old-fashioned uh movie fight speed round
here you too
um uh rain art city update channel asks
what's the best movie emma
oh we're talking like a real a real
person named emma in movies in movies i
guess it could be character or
or actor emma emma the movie
m in the movie from uh jane austen okay
and lon
um i'll i'll say emma thompson why not
okay uh danielle you get one minute
one whole minute okay um emma really
uh cares about her friends emma is a
friend to all emma is incredibly popular
um and we all popularity we know uh
speaks to
uh all of us in society uh emma is also
a very fashionable person
she comes from fine things and she falls
in love with
uh a a person that her dad introduced
her to
um and we're not gonna get into how or
why that happened but uh
but they fall in love and it makes it a
beautiful story and
uh just the way that she helps people
and she helps her friends and she helps
um those who wouldn't be accepted
all right lon emma thompson uh emma
thompson
is not only one of like the grand games
of modern filmmaking
appearances in tons of classic roles
classic films
uh that we all love but also an
accomplished uh writer
producer behind the scenes wrote the
beloved george michael based uh
holiday film last christmas just last
year so i mean
vital in front of and behind the camera
you gotta you gotta respect that plus
like sense and sensibility
dead again so many of these like classic
memorable films
also uh a bit part on cheers as
frasier's ex-wife
trivia wow i guess i forgot how short
speed rounds are because you still have
like 15. oh really well
i was going to call it there um uh the
audience
the one that i was going to say about
emma the character is
the best movie about her isn't even an
adaptation directly of emma it's
clueless in which she's played by alicia
silverstone and cher
i was just hoping y'all would yeah i was
just hoping y'all would forget about
clueless was really
good as if as if
uh well uh audience you be the judge um
uh subscribe for lawn and like for
danielle
there you go uh next week we'll be back
um for another corella honest trail
commentary
our new tuesday slot yeah the standard
uh no we will be back for another film
and your clue is it's not really i'm not
going to be specific i'm just going to
say that i could not believe that we
hadn't done this one already it really
slid through the cracks um
so i had the same reaction when i saw
this one come through writing some
historical wrongs
and um and filling in a gap uh so come
back next week to find out what that is
thanks so much for watching see you guys
later bye
[Music]
you